les premiers vaccins contre la carie 19
sont au pays
11h25 gisèle l'évêque 89 ans est devenue
la première canadienne vacciner d'un
vaccin comme pour la grippe ne fait rien
de dramatique
un vaccin tant attendu créés en un temps
record et distribué à l'échelle mondiale
après tous ces défis les autorités de la
santé font maintenant face à un autre
obstacle
[Musique]
l'hésitation à la vaccination
un phénomène amplifié par la montée des
théories du complot non mais je suis là
parce que nous voyons c'est ce qui rend
malade bien toutes sortes de trucs de
cochonneries dans les vaccins puis c'est
tout ceci est une mafia une grande mafia
médicale nous donner nous indique
clairement qu'il ya un lien entre
l'adhésion et non c'est complet depuis
le refus ou les décisions par rapport à
la santé connu les stations à la
vaccination comme une des plus grandes
menaces à la santé
depuis le début de la pandémie le
mouvement antivaccin marque des points
il capitalise sur la pandémie et la
montée du complotisme pour gagner des
adeptes et dans certains cas faire
mousser ses profits le lobby anti vaccin
est composé d'une clique de personnes et
compagnies très sophistiquée très
déterminés qui manufacture le doute bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a fait un montage de toutes ces
photos et des bons moments de sa vie le
thème
c'est sur cette photo là c'est celle là
réussi la rare de fait il ya une
douzaine d'années
linda morin a vécu un véritable
cauchemar bah ouais en 2008 sa fille
unique est décédé à l'âge de 14 ans deux
semaines après avoir reçu la deuxième
dose d'un vaccin contre le vph au label
et en santé avait jamais été malade ces
scènes ont enfin qui quant à eux étaient
des chevaux a attrapé au bout de tes
vives en mylar est enfin là y'avait n'y
a pas eu de signes avant coureurs pour
quelque chose comme ça arrive la coroner
a conclu que la jeune fille s'est noyée
dans son bain à la suite d'une perte de
conscience mais n'a pas été en mesure
d'établir ni d'éliminer un lien entre le
vaccin et le dessert thé chaud pour moi
c'est du vaccin
c'est trop chronologique
j'ai remarqué vous avez une page
facebook pour un label g la page
facebook depuis 2009
cette page facebook et militant anti
vaccins ont tenté de la prendre d'assaut
mais moi j'ai toujours privé mon jeu
privée justement pour filtrer pas 6 6
s'est pas privé ben tout le monde publie
n'importe quoi puis le le juge pas et le
contrôle linda morin ne souhaite pas
être associé à cette croisade est
aujourd'hui était pro vaccin je suis
encore au vaccin mais y'en a beaucoup du
complot tel le présentement à l'autre
est beaucoup beaucoup de failles de
complot qui rendent puis cgg public
piloté où je peux parler contre la
rougeole je veux pas parler compte
toutes les autres vaccins ce que je
trouve que les antilles l'axé c'est très
violent
ce genre de discours fait son chemin ici
données recueillies dans les derniers
mois démontrent que bien que la majorité
des canadiens demeurent trop vaccin ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux à se poser
des questions je pense que c'est normal
d'avoir toutes des questions des doutes
quand ça devient problématique c'est
quand on remet en question la science le
consensus scientifique danger c'est de
la science est très claire par rapport
au vaccin par rapport à l'efficacité la
sécurité des vaccins crise qui nous
inquiète aussi nos dernières données
nous montrent vraiment une hausse en
juin puis nos vins de l'indécision face
à la vaccination
c'est un peu particulier au moment où
l'on voit que le vaccin disponible quand
on commence à en plus de réponse nous
sur la vaccination békés une hausse de
licitation vaccinant
[Musique]
dans les bacs semaine
la popularité grandissante des idées
complotistes est en partie responsable
du phénomène
ça reste un phénomène minoritaire
je pense qu'il faut pas la différence
avoir des questions décret d'hésitation
par rapport à la vaccination et à être
un activiste raconte les vaccins kiprop
parole publiquement certains leaders de
mouvements didaxis ont mis un dialogue
avec par exemple des leaders de
mouvements extrêmes droites pour
partager toutes sortes de thèses
complotistes en éclats qu'ovide mais pas
que on peut penser par exemple des dicos
l'actu nonne qui sont sortis de
l'extrême droite puis sont bien de
partager aussi par des gens le plus
associé à ce dossier anti vaccins cette
synergie complétistes a donné du gaz au
mouvement vaccin partout à travers le
monde et a donné naissance à des
théories est un an mais une fois vous
avez reçu ça dans votre corps vous avez
des nanoparticules partout et là avec la
charge et on va pouvoir vous manipulez
vous détruire c'est de la folie pure
des fausses informations de ce genre ont
mené à des incidents inquiétants
oui ce concert pharmacie compléter cet
accusé d'avoir tenté de saboter plus de
500 doses du vaccin contre la copie
sur facebook ces actions sont encensés
par des membres d'un groupe nomi sos
québec qui compte plus de 10000 abonnés
une mauvaise nation au sitap haut lieu
on parle de thérapie génique sos québec
se dit pacifique mais s'est récemment
retrouvé dans la mire de l'équipe anti
terrorisme du spvm après avoir distribué
un tract qui comparait la vaccination un
génocide ordonnée avec l'aide de l'armée
canadienne
certains groupes qui s'opposent aux
vaccins se résume à une page facebook
mais d'autres sont beaucoup plus
sophistiqué
c'est très difficile de contrer ces
mouvements cela penche pas sur le même
tableau le dal fond quand on essaie
d'amener des arguments scientifiques ces
groupes là vont choisir certaines
parties des études en racheter d'autres
l'automne dernier quelques membres d'un
organisme international qui lutte contre
les discours haineux se sont immiscés
dans une conférence anti vaccins virtuel
ils ont constaté que les grands joueurs
de ce mouvement avait un message à
passer mais aussi des choses à vendre
comme des huiles essentielles des
suppléments et des formations
c'était comme si nous étions à une
conférence de gestionnaire en marketing
qui discutaient de comment vendre leurs
produits
c'était incroyablement banal mais aussi
effrayant car il utilise consciemment
l'aco vide pour semer le doute et que
leurs produits ultime mans c'est la mort
il vient d'un coup ils tentent de
remplacer les solutions développées par
la science par des solutions qu'ils ont
développée par eux-mêmes et qu'ils
vendent en passant parmi les invités
d'honneur de cette conférence on
retrouve andrew wakefield le
scientifique qui il y à 20 ans ont
publié l'étude bidon qui prétendait
établir un lien entre les vaccins et
l'autisme
[Musique]
plusieurs considèrent que whitfield est
à l'origine du mouvement antivaccin
moderne en 2019 nos collègues de siby
s'ils avaient infiltré une autre
conférence anti vaccin avec des caméras
cachées
la peur et la désinformation sont la
marque de commerce du lobby anti vaccins
et cette désinformation
ils la vendent sous forme de conférences
qui leur rapportent des milliers de
donne l'impression que leurs initiatives
sont menées par des membres du public
alors qu'en fait il s'agit de stratégies
sophistiquées
il essaie de vendre trois idées de base
premièrement que l'aco vie n'est pas si
dangereuse deuxièmement que nous ne
pouvons pas assurer la sécurité des
vaccins
et troisièmement pouvons nous vraiment
faire confiance aux médecins
ces trois idées maîtresses sont reprises
partout sur le web dans des articles qui
ont souvent la leur de publications
légitime mais attention pour cette
industrie
le trafic web représente également une
source de revenus
le contenu anti vaccin est souvent
publiés par des compagnies de produits
naturels des sites de fausses nouvelles
dans un corps par un site canadien
accusé d'avoir des liens avec des
réseaux de désinformation russe
l'opposition au vaccin est rarement
présentées de façon explicite
on utilise souvent un vocabulaire qui
parle de choix de liberté d'information
pour cacher les réelles intentions
et pour éviter la censure des réseaux
sociaux on est vraiment dans un contexte
beaucoup beaucoup d'informations de la
bonne information de la fox
d'information il ya de l'information qui
cherchent à nous alloue désinformées
clairement donc je comprends que ça peut
être complexe de s'y retrouver
le 30 janvier à los angele les militants
anti vaccins encerclent un des plus
importants centres de vaccination aux
états unis ils réussissent à provoquer
la fermeture du site pendant près d'une
heure
il
la peur des vaccins est plus répandue
est plus inquiétante chez nos voisins du
sud
plus de la moitié des américains aisés
tour refusent carrément de se faire
vacciner
certaines faust est partagé par l'ancien
président aurait contribué à cette
tendance
on sait que la vaccination comme
d'autres sujets de santé c'est très
politisé aux états unis donc ça peut
représenter une certaine vision
idéologie politique au québec on a été
traditionnellement protéger albi mais
c'est à dire que très très peu de ce
type de mouvement alors organiser ce qui
n'empêche pas l'opposition à la
vaccination d'être présente ici et cela
depuis l'avènement des vaccins en 1885
qui alors qu'une épidémie de variole
faisaient rage au québec une et molle
contre la vaccination obligatoire
s'était déchaîné devant l'hôtel de ville
de montréal
grâce aux vaccins que cette maladie qui
a tué et défigurer les milliers de
canadiens a été éradiquée un des leaders
du mouvement ce vaccin de l'époque était
alexander bros un médecin qui croyaient
qu'une bonne hygiène pouvait prévenir la
variole et que la vaccination était
dangereuse il comparaît notamment les
mesures sanitaires à une tyrannie un
vocabulaire encore utilisé cent trente
cinq ans plus tard
a contraint la faute médicale
j'accuse les médias de terrorisme
intellectuel
depuis quelques années avec la montée de
la droite du mouvement anti science
certains d'influenceurs ont commencé à
faire connaître la bandit ni à provoquer
une montée en flèche de leur popularité
ils arrivent ils voient des mesures
d'urgence sont là pour faire croire à la
population qu'on veut protéger la santé
et je pense que j'ai à ma gauche jean
jacques crèvecoeur qui va avoir un petit
mot à dire là dessus qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce changement c'est une des
voix les plus fortes du mouvement vaccin
francophones et celle de jean-jacques
rêve qu'à début février j'ai laissé
tomber mon activité professionnelle
principale pour me remettre au combat
puisque son opposition aux mesures
sanitaires fait l'immense est cpt mais
le militant n'est pas tombé de la
dernière pluie
mais arrêter une maxi nevo enfonce
enquête s'était déjà intéressé à lui en
2009 pendant la pandémie de la grippe
h1n1
à l'époque ils avançaient des théories
comme celle ci c'est un nombre de
guillotine ont été fabriquées pour
équiper les camps de concentration on
mettra ceux qui refuseront de la
vaccination
une version de cette rumeur a également
circulé cette année la da est en train
de construire 45 camps de concentration
sur l'ensemble du territoire canadien
dont quatre à montréal
il ne s'agit pas de camps de
concentration mais plutôt de sites de
quarantaine pour les voyageurs étrangers
forcément il ya des influenceurs qui
préoccupe au québec parce qu'il ya même
des gens dans une réalité alternative
pis le danger s'il suffit d'une personne
qui dévie pour qu' il peut y avoir de
graves dommages
un nombre donné il va y avoir des êtres
humains qui vont pas qu'ils vont
résister eux à cette élévation
vibratoire des êtres humains qui seront
restés dans la troisième dimension ne
verront plus les êtres humains qui sont
passés dans la cinquième dimension la
cinquième densité pour avec monsieur
mario dumont
d'origine belge jean-jacques crèvecoeur
et conférencier et auteur de plusieurs
livres
il détient également une formation
universitaire en physique théorique en
europe
ces activités sont sous la loupe
d'organismes qui enquête sur les dérives
sectaires
on s'inquiète notamment du fait que jean
jacques crèvecoeur fait la promotion de
médecine alternative jugée dangereuse et
qu il prétend que bill gates souhaite
utiliser les vaccins pour contrôler la
population donc bill gates présente des
pseudo arguments scientifiques pour
justifier le fait qu'il veut vacciner 7
milliards d'individus pour justifier des
politiques qui finalement sont quand
même des politiques de réduction de
populations ou entendez je vous entends
très bien en entrevue
jean-jacques red kerr a réitéré son
opposition aux vaccins en s'appuyant sur
des faussetés
ce n'est pas un vaccin covit 19
c'est une injection potentiellement
létale d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais
vacciner mes enfants effectivement et je
considère que la vaccination n'a jamais
été efficace n'a jamais apporté quoi que
ce soit d'intéressant en termes de santé
publique
confronté aux propos recueillis pour ce
reportage jean-jacques rêve car nous
accuse d'être de mauvaise foi et nie
avoir profité de la pandémie
ça fait 32 ans bordel de même ça fait 32
ans que je suis formateur
est ce que vous croyez que j'ai eu
besoin du coc vie de 19 pour me faire
une fortune
et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
millionnaire la notoriété de jean
jacques crèvecoeur a tout de même fait
un bond considérable pendant la pandémie
le nombre d'abonnés à chaîne youtube a
plus que doublé
j'avais deux cent trente mille abonnés
j'avais 13 millions et demi de vue rien
que pour la période qu'ovide du coin fla
j'étais trop influent je dérange est
trop cette chaîne a été fermé en juillet
dernier pour avoir contrevenu aux
conditions d'utilisation du site
mais sa page facebook est toujours en
ligne avec ses 340 mille abonnés et ses
fausses informations
vous en avez marre de vos grands-parents
ou de vos parents conseiller leur
simplement de se vacciner contre la
grippe saisonnière
cinq ans d'affilée et vous multiplierez
par 10 les chances de contraintes pour
eux de contracter la maladie d'alzheimer
des propos mensongers mais tolérée par
facebook
selon imran ahmed la complaisance des
géants du web s'explique par l'appât du
gain
les réseaux sociaux ont donné la portée
à ces gens là qui leur a permis
d'infecter autant de désinformation la
publicité représente 95% des revenus des
médias sociaux
alors ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on
continue à naviguer sur leur site afin
qu'ils puissent vendre de la pub le
trafic généré par les anti vaccin
représente un milliard de dollars au
géant des réseaux sociaux dans un
courriel facebook nous a dit qu'ils
identifient les pages qui partagent des
fausses informations sur les vaccins
afin de limiter leur importance dans le
fil d'actualité et qu'ils évitent de
recommander ce type de contenu
mais nous avons constaté qu'en cliquant
j'aime sur des pages facebook anti
vaccins le site nous proposait une foule
d'autres pages semblables
winnie on a besoin de mesures prises
maintenant pour s'assurer que ceux qui
tentent de miner la sécurité biologique
du monde entier ne pourront pas le faire
l'outil principal pour lutter contre ce
mouvement reste l'information le les
vaccins sont arrivés assez japonaise
française équipe de communication était
peut-être pas nécessairement ou tunis
mais le vide dans les discours autour
des vaccins n'a été comblé par les
acteurs qui sont pas nécessairement les
acteurs qu'on aurait souhaité qu'ils
prennent un espace en trop peu dans les
réseaux sociaux le ministère de la santé
et des services sociaux nous a dit que
le lancement de leur stratégie de
communication concernant le vaccin est
imminent je peux le fait que vous ayez
sur le vaccin chez comme je reprends de
la chance parce que j'ai du monde qu'il
faut que je vois je des parages procéda
pour mon père qui fait des dialyses
c'est cette raison qui m'ont sauvé la
vie après le décès d'un label me
s'accrocher aux autres facs aujourd'hui
dit il faut que je fasse pour l'autre
il va falloir que les gens se fassent
vacciner comme poche ou est ce qu'on
peut pas continuer comme cela ça peut
être bon sens et la ville est arrêté
[Musique]